♪
JEDEDIAH: HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AND FIRST RESPONDERS MAY BE
FIRST IN LINE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE, BUT AN
ALARMING NUMBER ARE REFUSING IT.
THE L.A. TIME IT IS REPORTING
40% OF LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS FAILED
TO EVEN SHOW UP AT A VACCINE
DRIVE LAST WEEK.
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. NICOLE SAPHIER IS HERE TO
REACT.
DOCTOR, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
OBVIOUSLY, WHEN YOU SEE STUFF
LIKE THIS, I THINK IT MAKES
PEOPLE NERVOUS BECAUSE THEY SAY
TO THEMSELVES, WELL, IF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AREN’T GETTING IT,
DO THEY KNOW SOMETHING I DON’T
AND SHOULD I WAIT?
>> OF COURSE, JEDEDIAH, AND I
CAN UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN.
IT’S NOT JUST THE L.A.
FIREFIGHTERS, IT’S ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IT’S HAPPENING FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
SOME PEOPLE FEEL THAT THEY DON’T
NEED IT, THEY DON’T BELIEVE THAT
THEY’RE HIGH ENOUGH RISK TO
EITHER CONTRACT IT OR THEY DON’T
BELIEVE THEY WOULD HAVE SEVERE
ILLNESS IF THEY GOT IT.
OTHERS HAVE SOME VACCINE
HESITANCY.
WE KNOW THAT RUNS RAMPANT
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES DUE
TO SOME CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT
PEOPLE ARE CLAIMING THAT THE
RESEARCH WAS RUSHED.
THERE WAS A LOT OF
POLITICIZATION OF THE SCIENTIFIC
PROCESS WHEN IT CAME TO MAKING
THESE VACCINES AND SO,
UNFORTUNATELY, IT HAS REALLY
MUDDIED THE WATERS, AND IT HAS
HAD AN UNFORTUNATE RESULT WHEN
IT COMES TO VACCINE.
IF YOU LOOK AT FLU VACCINES
EVERY YEAR, ABOUT 35-40% OF
AMERICAN ADULTS ACTUALLY GET THE
FLU VACCINE, AND THAT’S A LOT OF
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE FORCED
TO GET IT IF THEY WORK IN HEALTH
CARE SETTINGS.
SO WE KNOW A FAR MAJORITY OF
ADULTS DON’T ACTUALLY GET NORMAL
VACCINES ANYWAY, SO COVID-19,
I’M NOT SURPRISED THAT PEOPLE
AREN’T GETTING IT.
HOWEVER, JEDEDIAH, HERE’S MY
BIGGEST CONCERN.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE REALLY
NORMALIZED THIS VIRUS AND THIS
INFECTION BECAUSE IT’S BEEN
GOING ON FOR SO LONG, AND PEOPLE
HAVE COVID FATIGUE WHICH WE’VE
TALKED ABOUT, BUT, YOU KNOW,
JEDEDIAH, PEOPLE WHO GET IT SAY,
YOU KNOW, THEY HEADACHE THE
COMMENT I STILL HAVEN’T GOTTEN
MY SENSE OF SMELL OR TASTE BACK,
AND IT’S BEEN SEVERAL MONTHS.
LET ME TELL WHY THAT IS SO
SERIOUS.
THAT’S NOT JUST CONGESTION YOU
CAN’T SMELL YOUR COFFEE, THAT
MEANS THAT YOUR CENTRAL NERVOUS
SYSTEM HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY THIS
VIRUS.
AND LONG COVID SYNDROME, THOSE
SYMPTOMS THAT ARE LASTING THREE
MONTHS, SIX MONTHS AND EVEN
LONGER AFTER THAT INITIAL
INFECTION, THOSE ARE BECOMING
MUCH MORE COMMON IN ABOUT 20% OF
PEOPLE THAT TEST POSITIVE.
I MEAN, THAT’S A BIG DEAL,
JEDEDIAH.
THIS VIRUS IS SERIOUS.
WE STILL HAVE RECORD-BREAKING
PEOPLE BEING HOSPITALIZED AND
DYING EVERY DAY.
WE HAVE TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
I’M NOT SO INTERESTED IN WHO’S
GETTING THE VACCINE, BUT HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE GETTING THE
VACCINE, AND THAT’S WHAT WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON, GETTING THIS
VACCINE INTO AS MANY ARMS OF
AMERICANS AS POSSIBLE TO REACH
THAT LEVEL OF IMMUNITY SO WE CAN
MOVE ON WITH OUR LIVES.
JEDEDIAH: YEAH.
WE KNOW A LOT OF THE LINGERING
SYMPTOMS A NEUROLOGICAL.
I’VE HEARD A LOT OF THAT FROM
PEOPLE WHO GOT COVID SIX, SEVEN,
EIGHT MONTHS AGO.
I WANT TO QUICKLY TOUCH ON
SOMETHING IN NEW JERSEY WHICH IS
SMOKERS CAN GET VACCINATED
BEFORE TEACHERS AND PUBLIC
TRANSIT WORKERS.
WE ONLY HAVE ABOUT 20 SECONDS,
BUT CAN YOU TELL US YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> AGAIN, JEDEDIAH, WE NEED TO
JUST OPEN IT UP TO ANYBODY AND
EVERYBODY.
SMOKING, UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE
34 MILLION AMERICANS STILL
SMOKING CIGARETTES.
IT CAUSES CHRONIC ILLNESS AND
CANCERS, AND IF WE WANT TO KEEP
OUR HOSPITALS FUNCTIONING, WE
ACTUALLY DO NEED TO GET THE
VACCINE TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
VULNERABLE, AND PEOPLE WHO SMOKE
ARE, BUT AGAIN, I DON’T THINK WE
SHOULD LIMIT IT TO THEM.
WE NEED TO GET IT TO ANYBODY AS